he's doing fine he's doing fine it's as
far as I know from the last I heard he's
fine
Tiffany Haddish is opening up about
close friend Kevin Hart's health
following his car accident last week
she's gonna be starring in movies
together he'll be back up in atoms you
know he's already walking he's good yeah
he's good
his back on her his back his back on her
and you know he was making fun of me
because I saw my meniscus he was making
fun cuz I was wearing it when we was
going press for a secret life of pets
too I had a you know sleeve on my leg or
whatnot you know brace and he's making
fun of me talking my teeth you ain't
gonna getting up man you ain't no man
gonna want you with no brakes on your
leg you need to go get the surgery and I
said you know what I'm not I don't have
time to get surgery I'm gonna let my
body do what he do and heal itself and
look I'm rockin high-heeled and I'm
walking I might walk with a limp but
call me a pen and now I'm about to make
fun of you when you get back moving good
Kevin I'm coming for you I'm coming for
you back back break DT previously
reported that Hart was in the passenger
seat when he was involved in a car crash
near Calabasas California a source told
et on Friday that he fractured his spine
in three places meanwhile a second
source told et that Hart had been
heavily sedated since undergoing surgery
adding quote Kevin's spinal injuries are
very serious he sustained several
fractures and had no choice but to have
surgery as soon as possible the
physicians are doing everything they can
to keep him out of pain
[Music]